(crowd applauds)
- Oh my gosh.
You're like a dying breed,
the natural redhead.
It's so beautiful.
- Oh, thank you.
- I'm, like, jealous, I can't
ever keep red in my hair,
it won't stick, I tried so hard years ago.
- It really just falls out?
Like, as soon as you get in
the shower, its like, gone?
- Like, literally my hair rejects red.
I don't know.
Which is funny because my mom
has red in her hair naturally.
I don't get it either.
We don't need to know this.
(audience laughs)
Say hello to Mario.
- How are you?
- Hi Mario, how are you?
- I'm well, thank you.
I'm excited to see Willow.
I was just telling Kelly I
was a fan back in the day,
of the original.
- Yeah, we were around
when the original was...
(audience applauds)
- That must have been like 35
years ago or something, right?
- Yeah, it was '88, yeah.
- Yeah, woo.
- Oh my gosh.
- My math's not that good,
but it's, like, 30 something.
- Yeah, it's years.
Watch out though, he knows jiu-jitsu, so.
- I know.
Watch out, that'll save you.
- She could choke you.
- Did you play sports or do
anything like that growing up?
- I did actually.
I played a little bit of netball
and a little bit of hockey.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- So yeah.
- [Kelly] Hockey?
- Yes.
- That's fun.
- It was really fun.
- Did you slam people
into the walls and stuff?
- I mean, it was pretty aggressive.
We were on AstroTurf and we
did knock about quite a bit,
and, you know-
- Knock about.
I love your accent.
Okay.
(crowd laughs)
- Great expression.
- So did you know you
wanted to act early on?
- Yeah, I mean I always
just loved it at school.
I had this, like, really
passionate drama teacher
who used to put on
plays at local theaters.
And he was very serious about it,
like, members of the public
would come in and watch it
and it was quite an intense thing, yeah.
- That's cool that he's
serious about it though,
that made you more passionate about it.
- Yeah, definitely.
I mean, I was so passionate
that I remember one time
my parents would send me to Stagecoach,
like, after school and stuff,
and I'd fallen off a trampoline
and I went to Stagecoach,
because I was convinced
that I had to go even though
I wasn't feeling great,
and my elbow hurt a little bit.
And then at the end of
the day it turned out
that I had to go to A&E
because I had basically
broken my elbow, and I had
been, like, dancing all day...
- Adrenaline, it's beautiful thing.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, it is.
- It'll get you through some situations.
You're like, "I guess we
are powerful, humans."
That stinks.
But that sounds like fun though
to get to do at such a young age as well.
- Yeah, I loved it.
I was, like, really determined.
- Awesome, awesome.
Well, you're from the UK,
obviously, with your accent,
but you had to do a Texas
accent for one role.
- Yes.
- I'm curious how you mastered
that, it's very redneck.
(audience laughs)
- I loved getting to master it,
well, I mean, have a go at mastering that.
I watched so much Friday Night Lights.
Like, I think I watched
every single episode
over and over again.
- That series is actually based on a town
that's literally next to mine.
- No way.
- [Mario] Tyler, right?
- I'm telling you,
it's literally like every
small town in Texas.
That was a really good thing
to base your accent on.
(Ellie laughs)
- I loved it.
Like, I was totally obsessed.
Connie Britton was just, yeah.
- Oh my gosh, such a great...
Well, and he's not bad to look at.
- No, he's not bad.
- Yeah, he is very cute.
You've spent some time
in Texas as well, right?
Do you like Texas?
- Oh yeah, I a sister
that lives in Houston.
- [Kelly] Oh, right on.
- A lot of time in Texas.
- The food is pretty good.
Do you have an accent?
Do you have a Texas accent?
- I, like, adopt any accent I'm visiting
so I'll drop a lot of y'all's
after I leave outta Texas.
After I'm in New York,
I'll be talking like this.
You know, I'll just,
like, adopt whatever I...
- You adapt wherever you are?
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Kelly] Blend in.
- Yeah, I try.
- Well, okay, so you're
now in the Disney+ show,
it's a series, Willow,
which we know from when we were younger.
But tell us about the show, is it similar?
Is it kind of based
off of that, obviously?
- Yeah, so it's a kind
of a sequel to the film,
it takes place like 20 years
after the original film.
And it's about this
group of unlikely heroes
that go on a quest with Willow
to find our damsel in distress,
who is actually a prince.
So we go off on this
adventure and start, kind of,
discovering quite interesting
things about ourselves.
- There's quite a lot
of wit in it as well,
like, it's very funny.
- Yeah, it's quite a funny show, yeah.
I mean, we had a lot of fun making it.
We were in Wales and it
was really wonderful.
- It's pretty to look at,
scene photography was nice, yeah.
- [Kelly] Wales is pretty, yeah.
I love touring over
there, Wales is so pretty.
- So beautiful.
Like, the Brecon Beacons are just like...
Oh, it's so gorgeous, the
forests and everything,
so untouched.
- Just a fun show to do,
like, a fantasy type vibe,
that must be kind of fun,
because you're, like, talking
about magic, I love that.
- I do, I get to do a lot of magic.
- That's like, right up my alley.
So you must have had to
keep your character's
identity a secret for a while.
Is it hard?
Don't tell me anything if
you wanted to be a secret,
I'm not a good secret keeper.
Like, are you good at that?
- I definitely found it difficult,
and I also definitely found it difficult
when my castmates would play pranks on me.
So I actually had this
one time I received a text
from an unknown number, basically saying,
"I am from a tabloid
newspaper and I have-"
- That's wrong.
- "I have found out who your character is,
please can you send an image
to go with the article?"
And I freaked out.
I mean, I called everyone, like,
the whole of my team, everyone.
- And they're all laughing, no.
- No, they were all freaking out.
- [Kelly] Oh, I thought
they knew and were in on it.
- And Disney were freaking out,
like, someone spilled
coffee down themselves,
it was, like, a whole situation.
- Oh my gosh.
- And then I found out that it was Dempsey
who was in the show with
me, he had just been like-
- Oh, Dempsey.
- Dempsey, I mean-
- Dempsey's wilding out.
- Dempsey is so wild.
And he would just pull these
pranks again and again.
So every time he says something, I'm like-
- It sounded real, even
how he played it out.
- Yeah, totally.
But he just got...
I think he started to get
more and more extreme,
like, he said, like,
"Oh, I heard that you had
a really severe accident
at the read through."
And then I kind of was
like, hmm, I'm onto you now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
I love people that play pranks,
it keeps this set kind of fun as well.
- [Ellie] Definitely.
- Not for the guy who got coffee on him.
(Ellie and audience laugh)
But is it true that Ron
told you to take the magic
very seriously?
- Yeah, I got on a Zoom
with the whole team
and Ron told me that I really
needed to do some research
into magic and take it seriously.
And so I ended up, like,
running about London
to every, kind of, magic
shop that I could find,
and I kind of intensely studied magic
only to realize that the magic in our show
was totally different to anything
that I had actually discovered.
- But your card trick
game is on point now.
- Yeah, insane, yeah.
(crowd laughs)
- [Kelly] "But I can pull
a rabbit out of a hat."
- "Pick a card, any card."